If we zoom in on our terminal buttons, this is what we'll see. The joining of
the terminal buttons with the neighboring neuron is called the synapse. It
causes the release of a neurotransmitter. When the electrical impulse reaches
the terminal button, where all the neurotransmitters are. It causes a release
of the neurotransmitters into what we call the synaptic cleft. At this point,
the electrical impulse stimulates a chemical change, which releases the
neurotransmitters. The transmitters carry the signal across the synaptic cleft
to the next neuron. Finally the neurotransmitters reach the receptor sites that
only allow in particular kinds of neurochemicals, so it has to be a match. And
then the process starts all over again. Down the dendrite, through the soma,
down the axon, through the terminal buttons in the synapse and then reaches the
next neuron. This is the basis of how nerve cells communicate.